thank you so about ebo research we are a
small company which started about 13
months ago our team but our team has 10
years plus experience working in this
space and we have 23 development
partners with whom we work the last 12
months on developing a portfolio
analysis and planning solution for
science funders most of them are science
funders and we just released last Friday
the first commercially available version
of this one and our active members of
standards and data initiatives for
example case right orchid and we have
Laurie speaking tomorrow crossref and
fundraise and we are part of the digital
science family of small technology
companies working in the area of
supporting science digital signs is the
youngest sibling of the nature
publishing group which is owned by
Macmillan publishers small and big data
solutions to support science fender so
we're science funding happening it
happens on various levels so you have
supranational funders like the wh 0 the
European Union and others you have the
national level so the National Research
Council's which might be even specific
for different areas of science charity
organizations and corporate R&D so a lot
of players a lot of grounds a lot of
data being generated and if you then
look at the science system just taking
two pictures to illustrate science is
not happening in silos this is a
visualization from samar go where they
are looking at the different
geographical region regions and how they
collaborate and you can clearly see that
the color areas are not separated from
each other but overlapping which means
on an institutional level in fact which
we all know there is collaboration
happening internationally and it's also
happening on a personal level these are
just 800 8,500 physicians publishing on
one concept and these are the relations
amongst them one concept 8,500 just
imagine the millions of research
the number of concepts what type of
connected community that is in the end
so but science founders are funding
projects so that is the earliest point
in time where something becomes public
about which research is going to be done
and these supranational funders are
having perhaps three to fifteen
databases in which this information ends
up the National offenders have much more
databases in which the information about
the research which is going to be
carried out is ending up and if you
think of all the foundations and
charities that's even worse we are
leaving the corporate R&D which is a
black box at the site for the moment but
of course there's also happening a lot
but this is the area in which we are
interested in and I will explain why in
a second but all the players are
interested what the others are doing but
there's no means for them to
systematically analyze and tap into in
that information so interest is there
and why is interest there so if you look
for a second at the transmission
timeline from a scientific omalley
searcher having idea to having impact in
a way so there's the idea then he writes
a grant application the publisher might
or might not award we assume for a
second that he is awarding this ground
then the researcher will do research
will attend conferences he will present
the preliminary results and then he will
publish and at some point the citations
for a publication will pick up let's
look a second at the time frames from
ground to publication could be 125 years
depending on the type of research
citations being at the point where it
makes sense to analyze them and take
them into account is three to two years
normally so which means that between
grant and publication we talk about
three to eight years and why is that
important because the citation data is
currently driving the decisions what
should be funded or not to a large
extent
does that really make sense probably yes
to a certain extent but not as the
primary source of information so what we
have been doing is to focus on exactly
this point and we started to aggregate
something which is unfortunately not
publicly available yet a global database
of awarded grounds from various
publishers in order to allow various
players in the process to tap into the
information where scientific review
officers experts have made decisions to
bet on a certain area of research and a
certain proposal so we currently have a
portfolios from sixty funders with more
than 1.3 million grounds and growing
which cover more than 600 billion of
funding from which 166 are going to
happen in the future starting 2015 so
this is about resources which are going
to be spent on actual projects in the
future so a database which covers what's
going to happen which might be of
interest in some cases it's open for
funders to join and enel and benefit
both from the analytical capabilities
but we also make it available for the
entire scientific community in specific
use cases so for example we build a
small visit which allows researchers to
assign their awarded grounds to the
orchid record so that it's better
reflected in that system just a few
examples why it's important to know what
is happening imagine the European Union
is setting up a project called a small
project called horizon 2020 28 projects
are going to fund in the next year's 80
billion on research together they put it
in one pot and then I go and they're
going to distribute it in addition to
the funding which is happening on a
national level but there's no database
which is covering the 29 historic
portfolios of what has been funded in
the past what is currently going on to
allow the alignment of you
funding a national funding and as a
taxpayer in Germany I find this slightly
disturbing then if you look at a ground
a grant proposal from one researcher
being reviewed as a scientific review
versa I would be interested in knowing
whether this is an isolated project at
the institution or whether it actually
has a certain background a continent of
research in which it fits in nicely so
that even a smaller amount can have a
larger effect but also that requires the
information is there but it requires a
person to go to various places so what
what did we do we started to aggregate
the data and then we recognized as well
by that such a database didn't exist a
data cleansing data creation data model
mapping institution disambiguation
across the different sources person
disambiguation things we are working on
since 10 years but still it was hard
work to get to a reasonable data quality
when we built a functional layer on top
of it because data is not useful in
itself it needs to be analyzed so
natural language processing in order to
tap into the documents clustering a
topic topic modeling in the funders love
to use research classification systems
and in not a few cases they are still
assigning those texts to documents
manually a very expensive and not very
efficient way so dealing with ways how
to do this automatically has been a
great focus from us in the last month
then building search and analysis
application on top of it visualization
and most importantly provide this as
api's but since we started the company
after having built these kind of
analytical tools for large funders in
very expensive projects for more than 10
years we started the company in order to
allow also smaller and very small
funders to tap into the same
intelligence so what we did is we
implemented this as a cloud-based
solution which has since Friday even the
name dimensions as a product with
small founders can just use at a at yeah
marginal costs but we still allow others
to actually tap into the api's and build
their own applications leveraging the
data and the analytical capabilities
which we build into it and just a few
examples very simple ones because if the
title of the presentation is small in
Big Data Solutions it's basically the
database is can you can consider it to
be big data but it's mostly the small
solutions which are helping to solve the
everyday challenges of people for
example processing grant applications
it's not necessarily being able to
detect what the trend in the next five
years is based on computational routines
that is nice but sometimes the
challenges are much more down to the
ground and let's pick a few examples
which I was able to pull up in a few
minutes so we all are familiar with ALS
and what has happening over the last few
weeks but the question is right not
right now what is going to happen with
these 100 million what should be done in
order to invest this in a way because we
cannot expect that everybody is donating
the same amount next year so it will be
a one-time effect at least to a certain
extent and it's a tricky situation which
is comparable to the error funding from
the US government a couple of years ago
because it can cause negative effects
short-term boost research projects take
longer than one year normally so do you
bolt on to other projects so what are
you going to do because the public is
expecting now that something is
happening so just typing in a very basic
query it shows me immediately what is
currently going on approximately
thousand projects are currently 1
billion going into research on this
disease with approximately 1 million as
an average funding amount for the
project if I look at the graph I see
that it has been rising similar to the
overall research funding
which I know and the active project is
the green line starting project is the
blue line so and if we then look at the
average funding amount it becomes clear
that the annual average funding amount
is currently around 1 million so this
year or in the next month the double
amount can be spent and who is actually
funding it so based on the data which we
aggregated you can get a clear picture
who has been funding research in this
area perhaps to think about how to not
isolate in an isolated wife and research
right now but setup corporations between
funders in order to coordinate in an
area of research like ALS or you can
within seconds tap into who which funder
has been funding which research
organization with which amount over the
last years in order to understand where
the money has been going so for example
Johns Hopkins received 34 grounds
relevant to the query which we entered
in which approximately 50 million and
one point four million per project if we
look into the researchers who have been
receiving these funds then we can tap in
immediately into and analyze what type
of research has been done so for example
if you look at Jeffrey he has 10 home
projects in total out of which I think
for van remember correctly are relevant
to ALS but we get an impression
immediately what he's doing in order to
perhaps even assess his proposal but now
the question is what to do with it and
forgive me I'm only a medical doctor so
the example is relatively simple and not
going into the genetic causes of the
disease but assistive technology is of
interest for ALS patients and perhaps
it's a good area to invest part of the
money going forward because it yields
immediate effect and you might be even
able to tap into developments which are
happening elsewhere so currently 13
projects are dealing with it topic of
assistive technology and a less but more
than 680 with overall and if I'm
a a program officer being tasked to get
rid of a part of the 100 million in a
useful way I could do a very quick
analysis and what type of assistive
technologies are not being researched or
developed on with ALS and try to tap
into those in order to perhaps even
approach people to go and apply what
they have done in a way that it fits for
the ALS patients just as and that's what
I meant with simple data solutions
nothing else than a search application
with the with some intelligence and
natural language processing behind it
but it allows me to very flexibly query
it and make it and create supporting
insights for decisions which have to be
made and which have to be defendable
other things are of course trying to
understand better the portfolio of a
science funder and so what we did and
submitted in a contest of the British
Library which we want is to create
visual representations of portfolios
based on research classification so what
you see here is the overall amount of
funding with categories used from the
NIH or reporting and the size of the
bubble shows the amount of projects and
money and the relation is how related
these are in terms of the analysis of
the documents but you can then highlight
one for example rural health and it
helps you then profounder what type of
importance and which topics are in the
area of rural health connected with this
funder to allow to to support very
specific analyses and with visual
impressions last but not least a more
practical example every science founder
has the challenge that oh in every
decision foreground the communities
involved by the means of peer review so
peer reviewers have to be identified in
order to support making the decisions
which project should be funded and the
hard work is actually finding peer
reviewers we have the right expertise
and no conflict of interest so by
tapping into the database which we that
was not a peer reviewer and by tapping
into the database we analyzed the
automatically the grant application
which comes in and flows into the system
automatically and then we suggest
immediately the best matching peer
reviewers based on both their grounds
and publications and we compute
potential conflicts of interest based on
co-author relation based on
institutional affiliation or co-funding
with the same publisher and allowing so
the funding agency to bring down the
time to identify reviewers but also
increase the quality of the match
between an application and a reviewer by
tapping into much more information
sources than a human being would be able
by only using a search application these
were three very simple examples not the
ones where we're looking at trends which
require more than 20 minutes since I'm
unfortunately have to leave this evening
due to family emergency i would like to
point to my co-founder ashley who is
altering the audience so if you have
questions tomorrow i will be here today
the entire day this is the guy to go to
thank you very much
you